ich finde ich bin ich
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
heute sind auch timo ja und wir haben
wieder der alte auch stoltenbergs
genanalysen wir heute wieder ein förster
allein das hat mal wieder
ich möchte darauf hinweisen dass es
jetzt gerade halb fünf ist morgens 34
und wir jetzt einfach auf die mode sind
nicht aufnehmen lasst uns standen nicht
entspannen und wie man fest dass wir
zuerst ja es hat gewinnt das ist fast
five winds hat man ja daran merkt ihr
wie früher ist es dann ohne 1 film ab
und da sind wir noch nicht gehabt hast
du gerade
ich will einfach niemand kleinholz
machen meine tnt kenner ist es ohne
instant dieses ohnehin sind kann aber
nicht
alter oder ich gut geflogen alte trank
der stärker als ob ich okay
bemerkung benni barg kommt
scheiße neues freies feld muss ich gar
nicht weg
frisst das ist gar nicht so schlecht ist
neben hass sie abgebaut
die sind ja überall luftmine katja
leisten
sie lacht haben weil ich doppelt und
dann will ich mich bringen runde nummer
zwei bin fit ich muss dringend
ausstellen kann das ausstellen
das bestellt hast ich kann nicht sagen
ich kann gar nicht suchen frage sagt
dass man super für mich
ja und aber für mich reizt solo idee da
sind wir ein feuerzeug schärfe drews
alles schick verzaubert hex hex hex hex
also diese rangelow all deine range
alter dass wir die frankfurter ekel
range alter herr wir bis jetzt getötet
man ja frage ich mich habt ihr doch viel
mehr gegeben eigentlich herr blöcke
parlamente was das vielleicht ich glaube
das ist ja exakt empfiehlt blockierten
warum spricht in austria kraft 83 15
jetzt bringen die schweizer taktik und
wenn weiter täglich wie ganz normale
leute die ich lese getroffen
hermann kues und tastatur so krasse
doppel hielt altern dem speaker kanal
ich komme ich mal die range alter wie
mache ich das ich höre ist dass
blockierten mega heftiger der ich rate
auch zu blocken hill vierten runde in
die wir entschädigen
heute wenn er darauf bestanden dass wir
es nicht auch haben sie die aktivierte
sparkurs als ob kann man super herz voll
ist
ich weiß nicht ich verpasse mir kurz
fall schaden ja ja man kann
wahrscheinlich ist auch nach gewicht und
alter leute okay das heißt der 15 uhr
guten wird wahrscheinlich nicht mehr
arrogant entwickelt
ich weiß was passiert was passiert ich
bin ich super glücklich ganz so was von
nicht suchen also das heute kriegt noch
so halbwegs den würde ich sagen also
auch immer schön auf die suppen rodkin
geht klar nein nein
oh gott jetzt mich so risiken können
jetzt alter habe ich verdrückt man eher
kampf ist warum habe ich keine roten
pilz glaubt hast ich schwöre ich hab
keine roten pilze wenn das gut läuft als
der linse
haha wie sich nichts vormachen
ich bin da krasse damage die da kannst
du kein spiel mehr diese und eigentlich
noch hält er trotzdem noch riesige das
nicht da bin ich kurz mal hängen
geblieben doch stehen denn als auch bei
gruppen und lampen an meiner macht wie
lange er selbst noch weglaufen
ruhrort kind läuft also die hotkeys
erwische ich aber nur das suchen refill
das kann ich gar nicht was mir viel mehr
schaden als ich da bin ich doch ganz
nahe dran mein freund da muss man nein
ich habe ich immer gewonnen aber ich
habe nicht mit maus hat gesagt ich hab
mit hotkeys gesucht und es ging sogar
fix das ist viel zu null kann das sein
doch okay wir springen in runde fünf so
leute dritte runde und das ist glaube
ich dein eigenes kind kann das sein pass
auf abgehoben und ich freue mich dass
mein drittes ich glaube da doch kann
soll das nicht das hat er sehr viel
schatten
ein problem so leute wer mir
alter schwede das wird eine kurze runde
jetzt geht's ab habe ich gefühl kann das
sein
da kann man runter nicht gesehen sagt
mir doch mal hallo hier und da mal hoch
mal daran ist er solo ground gegeben
hast du mich noch fast geklärt
das herz als optiker so geis die immer
so zu gucken oder kenne ich paket sich
ziemlich gerne wir eigentlich nicht aber
ich mache ja nicht sein dass man gegen
weniger aus tanz für mich geehrt 52 sich
gewonnen zwei bewegungen nein muss ich
weg bin
man regeneriert ja ich wollte noch mal
kurz sagen ohne scheiß über regeneriert
man nicht was wir schon aus mein freund
der übelste ab dachte ich kann jetzt
schon erkennen
ich find ich bin ich finde ich ja weiß
gott ist der 3 oktober bis märz alter in
your face so einfachen lacker das gibt's
mit dem herzen hat wirklich nur hey du
weißt wie man nicht nennen sollte donna
d alter lucky halbes herz das gibt es ja
nun eigentlich nach texten die ich ja
eigentlich auch jetzt ein schlag treffen
es wird spannend leute nicht so eine
längst führt knapp korrekt das ist der
kleine riehen hat speed alter wenn sowas
mega scheiße
solo bist du nicht du [ __ ] jana ina
geib bekommt erhält
ich dachte nicht dass du noch mal hast
du noch mal trinken deine haut packe ich
habe viel fällt das war spannend denn
dank fürs mitmachen